hola hoy en saint click el sistema solar
el sistema solar es el conjunto de
objetos atraídos por el sol
en el primero se encuentra una estrella
el sol es de lejos el objeto más masivo
del sistema del cual también es su
centro alrededor del sol gravitan
objetos más pequeños
luego encontramos cuatro planetas con
superficie rocosa también conocidos como
planetas terrestres
mercurio es el más pequeño y el más
cercano al sol venus con una atmósfera
tan densa que por efecto invernadero
posee una temperatura superficial
extremadamente alta alcanzando hasta 500
grados centígrados la tierra que es el
más grande de los planetas rocosos en su
superficie encontramos agua líquida y
organismos complejos con vida además
posee un satélite la luna que orbita
alrededor de él
y por último se encuentra a marte el
planeta rocoso más alejado del sol marte
posee dos pequeñas lunas fobos y deimos
situado a espaldas de marte encontramos
un gran cinturón de asteroides está
compuesto por cientos de miles de
pequeños detritos rocosos estos
asteroides pueden en ocasiones salir de
sus órbitas y por casualidad llegar a la
tierra en forma de meteoritos
detrás del cinturón de asteroides hay
cuatro planetas gaseosos sin superficie
sólida cada uno es una esfera de gases
que se mantienen unidos alrededor de un
núcleo denso por la atracción
gravitacional
el primer planeta gaseoso es júpiter se
trata del más grande de todos los
planetas del sistema solar en su
superficie hay potentes vientos y
tormentas extremadamente violentas como
júpiter es tan masivo su atracción
gravitatoria es considerable y posee más
de 60 lunas que orbitan a su alrededor
tales como europa y ganímedes
le sigue saturno un poco más pequeño y
rodeado por una multitud de anillos
concéntricos
estos anillos están formados por
fragmentos de roca y hielo que orbitan
alrededor del planeta saturno también
posee más de 60 lunas no es el único
planeta que tiene anillos a su alrededor
sin embargo los anillos de saturno son
mucho más visibles que los de cualquier
otro planeta detrás de saturno se
encuentra urano y luego viene neptune
estos dos planetas gaseosos son mucho
más pequeños que los dos anteriores
aunque siguen siendo mucho más grandes
que la tierra también poseen algunos
anillos poco visibles
urano posee unas 30 alumnas mientras que
neptuno el más pequeño de los planetas
gaseosos tiene alrededor de 20
los planetas rocosos y los planetas
gaseosos no están solos en el sistema
solar también existen varios planetas
enanos que son mucho más pequeños que
los anteriores pero más grandes que
simples asteroides entre los planetas
enanos se encuentran por ejemplo seres
el mayor objeto del cinturón de
asteroides
o plutón que posee una serie de lunas
como caronte knicks o cervero más allá
se encuentra un nuevo cinturón de
asteroides conocido como cinturón de
kuiper
y por último detrás del cinturón de
kuiper se encuentran una multitud de
pequeños objetos como los cometas que
orbitan alrededor del sol desde muy
lejos es lo que llamamos la nube de oort
aunque el sistema solar se conoce mejor
que nunca no hay consenso sobre dónde
están sus límites la definición más
común sitúa el final del sistema solar
justo después de la nube de oort pues a
esta distancia la atracción gravitatoria
al sol es tan débil que casi no se
siente en todo caso el sistema solar no
puede reducirse a los ocho planetas que
conocemos es un complejo inmenso repleto
de objetos que aún están por descubrir
para entender mejor la escala la
extensión del sistema solar es al menos
100.000 veces mayor que la distancia que
separa la tierra del sol y sin embargo
nuestra estrella es sólo una entre miles
de millones de hecho en el universo
existe una increíble variedad de otros
sistemas estelares con planetas aún
totalmente desconocidos y quizás hasta
con otras formas de vida diferentes a
las que se encuentran en la tierra
[Música]